The most critical need that any person facing the death poly has a or facing any
criminal charge,
uh,
is the need for a lawyer.
A lawyer is,
uh,
indispensable to investigating the case against the person who's accused,
mounting a defense.
If the person accused says that there are witnesses who can show that he or she
was somewhere else at the time of the trial,
the lawyers,
the person who's responsible for going and finding those witnesses for putting
them under subpoena for bringing them to court,
uh,
so they can testify.
Uh,
the lawyers also,
uh,
responsible for all protection,
all the legal rights that a person accused of a crime has.
And if the lawyer doesn't raise those issues,
uh,
they might as well not exist at all,
at least for that person.
So it's critically important that a person facing the death punny have the
lawyer who's competent,
who knows the law,
who has the resources to the investigation that's necessary.
And as we'll discuss in a capital case,
there's going to be a need to do and even greater investigation of the life and
background of the client that,
that lawyer serving.
Uh,
who's facing the death poem.
There's also a need for other people though as well,
or other parts of the defense team.
One is an investigator.
Uh,
that case is going to require investigation both,
as I said,
of the crime.
The prosecution may rely upon identification that is mistaken.
Uh,
it may rely upon witnesses who have traded,
uh,
favors and for their testimony who may be unreliable.
Uh,
it may be that,
uh,
there are a lot of factors going to the question of guilt that requires
interviewing witnesses,
talking to people about what they saw,
what they heard,
what other people told them.
All of those things that as we know,
are critical in determining guilt or innocence.
And then finally,
today,
uh,
in the criminal justice system,
the use of expert testimony,
uh,
is important as so much use of everything from fingerprints to DNA evidence,
that are prosecution may present,
uh,
in support of prosecuting someone.
So the question is how does the defense respond to that?
And if the defense does not have its own investigator or if the lawyer defending
a person facing the death penalty can't consult with an expert.
And I'm an investigator,
an expert,
not an investigator,
you need to talk to someone who's an expert in that area.
Uh,
the lawyer will in order to be prepared to present that well,
what if you don't have any of these things?
Uh,
what if you have no money?
Diego Morin,
uh,
accused of the death penalty and facing the death pointing of del Rio,
Texas,
uh,
eight months,
eight months in jail without a lawyer.
So there's no lawyer to start an investigation,
no lawyer to start preparing this case.
Obviously it gives the prosecution a tremendous advantage.
Uh,
when the person accused does not have a lawyer.
Eventually he got a lawyer,
but it was eight months after his arrest and,
uh,
prop appointment of lawyers and then the lawyer having access to investigative
and expert assistance is going to be critical.
Well,
as we talk about this,
we'll look at,
uh,
to uh,
critical parts of the constitution.
First,
the due process clause of the 14th amendment.
And as we will see and we talk about,
uh,
the case of Griffin versus Illinois in just a minute.
Different justices have different ideas what exactly due process means,
but basically fundamental fairness.
What do we provide this person that they have a fundamentally fair opportunity
to present their case within the adversary system.
It is an adversary system.
The prosecution is going to be presenting its case with all the,
uh,
the advocacy that it can to try to convince the jury of its point of view.
Uh,
and the question is,
what does a state have to provide a poor person,
uh,
to counter that other critical constitutional provision is the sixth amendment,
of the United States constitution.
Uh,
which,
um,
means that every person who's on trial a is entitled to a lawyer to represent
them at trial.
Notice this just applies to trial.
We'll talk in a moment about lawyers for appeals and other parts of the process.
Uh,
but we'll,
we'll start talking about due process,
uh,
this constitutional provision by looking at a case out of Illinois,
which was some time ago,
uh,
but gives us a,
the first time the court wrestles with this question of a poor person who needs
something,
uh,
and is asking for the state to provide it.
Griffin versus Illinois 1956 this case involve two people,
Judson Griffin and James Crenshaw,
who were convicted of armed robbery in Chicago.
In order to appeal in Illinois,
you have to have the transcript of the trial.
Of course,
while at trial is taking place.
The court reporter is taking down verbatim everything that the witnesses,
the judge,
the lawyers say.
And that's what an appellate court uses to review the fairness of the trial.
He's fall,
say,
we can't afford a transcript.
Uh,
and they argue that under the due process clause,
uh,
that as a matter of fairness,
they're entitled to this transcript.
And also if they don't get it,
that they're being treated differently because of their poverty.
Uh,
then other people was the close case.
the Supreme Court decides five to four,
uh,
that they're entitled to a transcript.
A justice black writes the opinion for four members of the court that the
states,
uh,
if you provide an appeal,
you can't deny access to the appeal by denying a transcript.
One of the arguments in the case had been there's no right to appeal or the
constitution only provides the right to trial and a right to a lawyer at trial.
Uh,
but the court looked at the fact that basically every state,
every jurisdiction provides for an appeal,
appeals or just part of the system.
And if the system is going to be fair,
the appellate review of what happens in the trials is a critical component of
that.
And therefore Griffin and Crenshaw are entitled to a transcript so they can
appeal their case.
Uh,
justice black gives some very sweeping language here.
There can be no equal justice when the kind of justice a person gets depends
upon the amount of money here she has,
of course,
that's a noble ideal and the supreme court building has equal justice under law,
uh,
at the front door.
But we will see that equal justice under law remains an aspiration as opposed to
reality.
Uh,
very often in the criminal courts.
and very often,
uh,
in capital cases,
the fifth vote was provided by Justice Frankfurter.
Uh,
and he basically said,
just as a practical matter if we're going to have appeals,
we can't keep poor people.
Uh,
from having,
uh,
the lawyers to represent,
excuse me,
transcripts,
uh,
of the trials.
Now Justice Harlan dissented,
uh,
for,
for members of the court,
he felt there was no violation of equal protection because he said this cost of
transcripts applies to everybody.
It applies to say,
just like tuition to a university.
Some people can afford to pay the tuition and some people can't,
but the government is not discriminating by charging tuition.
Uh,
and therefore this is not discrimination against poor people because they can't
afford a transcript.
He also says there's no due process violation.
A,
because it says due process,
at least as he sees it.
And he defines it as not implicit in the concept of ordered liberty and not
traditionally regarded as necessarily the fundamental fairness.
What does that mean?
Basically,
how have we always done it?
If we haven't provided transcripts to poor people in cases up until now,
why suddenly should we change?
Why does the due process clause,
uh,
suddenly have a provision in it that it didn't have,
before?
Uh,
basically justice Harlan is saying federalism,
leave it up to the states.
The United States Supreme Court shouldn't decide whether people get transcripts
or not.
Uh,
this is a very close case,
uh,
but a very important case because we will see that it becomes important a few
years later and giving people the right to a lawyer,
uh,
for appeal.
Uh,
but what about the right to a lawyer at trial?
Once you have a transcript,
of course you need a lawyer and when you're accused of a crime and once you're
at trial,
uh,
you have a right to a lawyer.
Power versus Alabama,
which we looked at earlier,
involve the young men in Scottsboro,
uh,
facing the death pony there.
The Supreme Court said that in that case,
the sort of casual appointment of lawyers who really had not prepared and sort
of stumbled through the case wasn't a violation right to counsel on the sixth
amendment because it didn't apply to the states then,
uh,
but it was a violation of due process.
They were denied a fair trial,
uh,
in Johnson versus [inaudible].
Uh,
the Supreme Court held that in federal cases,
the sixth amendment right to counsel required that poor people accused of a
crime who could not afford a lawyer,
uh,
should be provided one a.
And for a while,
uh,
the court said that in state courts it depended case by case.
In some cases you might be entitled to a lawyer if the case is complicated and
so forth.
But if it's a simple case and,
uh,
the defendant can represent himself,
then you're not.
Powell basically stood for the proposition that everybody in a capital case was
entitled to a lawyer.
Um,
but what happened in 1963 was this man here,
Clarence Earl Gideon wrote this five page.
This is the first of a five page petition that he wrote to the Supreme Court of
the United States getting had been tried for breaking into a pool hall in a Bay
Harbor,
Florida.
He'd been convicted.
He had asked for a lawyer at trial.
The judge said,
you're not entitled to one.
It's a simple case.
There's no reason you should get a lawyer.
Uh,
and the case goes to the Supreme Court on Gideons handwritten petition,
uh,
and the supreme court holes in Gideon versus Wainwright unanimously with justice
black writing for the court,
that any person who is too poor to afford a council to afford a lawyer who's
hailed into court,
charged with a crime is entitled to a lawyer.
So,
uh,
now the states have the responsibility of providing lawyers,
but,
but of course there's this is,
is if ever there is an unfunded mandate,
this is it.
And what are the states doing response Florida where Gideon had been tried
immediately within three months of the Supreme Court decision,
adopted a statewide public defender system,
but many other states that didn't provide lawyers to people conscripted lawyers.
If you practice law in a place,
a part of the privilege of practicing law was that every so often you were
assigned a criminal case and the lawyer had to represent the person even though
the lawyer might be a tax lawyer,
a real estate lawyer,
a divorce lawyer,
uh,
that,
that was,
uh,
just part of being a lawyer.
Of course that resulted in very poor legal representation.
Since the lawyers a didn't want the job,
a B didn't get paid anything for it and see often lacked the expertise needed,
uh,
to provide representation.
Uh,
in a case.
Well,
there are different ways in which states have provided,
uh,
representation.
Uh,
public defender programs are programs in which you have full time.
Lawyers who are trained and supervised usually have a staff of investigators,
social workers,
uh,
in some states now have capital defender offices in Virginia for example,
for regional capital defender offices obviously is that specialize in
representing people in death penalty cases.
Uh,
the same thing in Georgia.
The capital defender office created in 2005,
the Virginia one,
uh,
once after that,
Colorado for a long time,
uh,
has had an outstanding capital unit within its public defender system that
represents people.
Uh,
but in a lot of other states,
uh,
there is no capital defender office.
And often as we'll talk about the lawyers representing people in death penalty
cases,
uh,
may not quite be up to the task.
Uh,
another system is a what's called panel programs are assigned counsel.
Basically lawyers are unlist and the judges may appoint from the list.
That's the panel is,
is the list or the judge.
It's just my appointment.
People they know.
Uh,
and one of the problems that we see is that judges elected judges appointing
lawyers that they know,
uh,
to represent people in cases.
Often the lawyer may be more loyal to the judge who appointed the lawyer and who
the lawyer depends upon for his or her livelihood.
Uh,
then the client,
uh,
that they're representing a,
another system has contracts.
Basically a lawyer or a law firm,
contracts with a jurisdiction,
uh,
to represent every person accused of a crime must as a conflict of interest.
Uh,
in cases,
a lot of jurisdictions like this because it's cheap,
but it also is a very high volume,
a poor quality system.
Most of the time,
of course,
not all the time,
but most of the time.
And then finally,
uh,
there is still conscription,
less and less than there was,
uh,
50 years ago.
Uh,
but in Louisiana,
a lawyer can still be drafted to handle the case,
including a death public case.
Um,
so,
um,
in,
in considering all of these programs,
I would say that the public defender program is the one where there is the
greatest likelihood that you're going to have specialization.
A,
you're going to have supervision,
uh,
and training of the lawyers,
which in capital cases is critical.
Uh,
because,
uh,
capital cases are incredibly complex.
They involved a complex area of the law.
They involved additional investigation,
uh,
that has to be done.
And so some specialization is helpful,
but you will find,
we will find that in many places just simply any lawyer who's a member of the
bar may be appointed to represent someone in a death penalty case.
Um,
in 1976 when the supreme court struck down the,
uh,
mandatory death pony statutes,
they said in a case out of North Carolina Woodson versus North Carolina,
uh,
that the jury cannot be precluded from considering,
any of the compassionate or mitigating factors about the individual facing the
death Poli,
uh,
that arise from the diverse frailties of humankind two years later and lock it
versus Ohio.
The court said the sensor cannot be precluded from considering any aspect of the
defendant's character record,
uh,
that is offered for a sentence less than death in the case of lockup vs Ohio.
Um,
the same time the court upheld the death penalty and Greg versus Georgia,
the prevailing opinion said accurate sensing information is indispensable for
the death penalty to be carried out in a constitutional and fair manner.
Uh,
of course,
that puts tremendous responsibility on the defense lawyer to do the
investigation,
which those cases require.
That is to look at the life history of the person,
everything about their life,
any mental issues that may be in the case,
any intellectual disability,
uh,
or any other as a case,
as the court said,
diverse frailties of humankind,
that may be a mitigating factor.
It doesn't explain away or justify the crime,
but it's something that jury takes an account in measuring culpability.
Uh,
we will see,
unfortunately,
that sometimes lawyers are not up to the task of doing that.
And as a result,
that critical information,
probably the most important information at the penalty phase of a capital trial
may not be presented.